as far as serb godparents occur so we
were talking about that when we were
filling the many many hours down here at
the Lindo wing they would they went for
people that we weren't particularly
anticipating last time didn't they so
seven godparents for Prince George they
went for friends of Diana's friends of
Prince Charles's also some close friends
that they knew from university but they
didn't go for their direct brothers or
Cygnus and do you think this time around
we could potentially see godparents made
out of Prince Harry or Pippa Middleton
James Middleton well of course they were
the best man and the matron of honor and
not that they missed out I've got
parents last time because they did have
that great honor at the wedding but I
think it's it's very possible and I
think you'll see the choice of
godparents again will reflect their
close friends you know this is not a
stuffy family this is a very modern
royal couple they want to do things
their way and they want Prince George in
his sibling to be surrounded by people
that they as a couple love and and value
and they want those values passed on to
their children I think it was a lovely
choice they had last time around get
from reading up traditionally members of
the royal family may choose people who
are outside of their direct family
because they want outside influences
people outside of the family that can
advise and be there for them and I
rustic rats and members of the European
royal family that's all very traditional
and an animal is quite archaic I mean
when you're choosing your godparents you
choose people that you want to instill
the values that you share and the couple
of turn to those friends like you Sara
and the friends from university but yeah
I hope it will be hipper and Harry among
that it's seven godparents probably so
quite a few well I hope it's today
because it's my goddaughters birthday
today so tonight if it was today
hello Matilda